let's take a break from the monsterverse
and go into another monster universe in
this video today i will be talking about
one of hp lovecraft's most intriguing
and mysterious characters aside
azeroth is just one of many diverse and
interesting characters within the
cthulhu mythos
that we will be exploring in this and
other upcoming videos
the cthulhu universe is a vast one with
many strange
or inspiring and terrifying deities and
creatures
here i will be talking about the origins
nature and powers of this particular
character
and what sets him apart from other
characters in this universe
the name azdoth is first mentioned by
h.b lovecraft himself
in a note in 1919 where he describes the
name as being hideous
but the first actual appearance of
azdoth as a proper character in
lovecraft's fiction
is in the story the dream quest of
unknown kadat
here the author describes this deity as
a sultan ruler of a realm beyond the one
we models are familiar with lovecraft
explains that this
realm is one marked by chaos and
confusion the opposite of our own
it is from this story that one of
azeroth's many names
the demon sultan is also derived
azeroth is known as the nuclear chaos
the blind idiot god
but just to be clear lovecraft was not
thinking of atomic power when he was
describing azeroth
in the story of the whisperer in
darkness the word nuclear can be seen as
a reference to the center of the cosmos
in which this god resides now the
reference to azdoth as being
blind and an idiot can be seen in the
story the haunt of the dark
and as darth is also described as being
mindless in the dream of the witch house
the name the blind idiot god however
must not be equated with the idea that
azeroth must be somehow stupid
we must keep in mind that lovecraft was
an atheist and hence for him
the universe is not characterized by
some kind of ultimate meaning
as a dot then can be seen as a living
force whose ultimate book has a living
force whose ultimate purpose
our destiny is not clear or even evident
at all
this is what partly contributes to the
mystery and confusion surrounding his
character
gods are usually portrayed as having a
goal or a tendency towards one
however in azeroth's case there is no
conscious driving towards one
he just simply exists now all gods have
their own age distinctive abilities and
powers
accordingly the deities in this
mythological universe are divided into
four
major groups the outer gods the elder
gods
the great old ones and the other gods
are the great ones
the outer gods are those who have been
in existence far
longer than the actual beginning of this
universe itself
one can even go so far as to say that
they are primeval in nature
keep in mind that while the terms the
outer gods and the other gods are used
interchangeably at times by some people
the former are more powerful than the
latter
at times one gets the impression that
aztar thoughts and even cthulhu himself
since he has been described as being
cosmically boundless and there is an
inclination to think of him as being
omnipotent as well
this is especially true if we take into
consideration that asda's real name
is rather a mystery and that it is not
listed even in a necronomicon
however it is believed that his real
name if it is ever to be mentioned will
instill fear in the hearts of both
men and gods hence one can view aside as
being a formidable opponent for
anything for the other gods the great
old ones
since he might be the father of all
creation and we live in his dream
one of the factors we must take into
account is that other writers have also
contributed to this universe
among them is august derelict who wrote
the novel the lurker in the threshold
here as doth is depicted as in a similar
fashion
to john milton's lucifer in paradise
laws both
take on the role of a rebel and are
punished for it while lucifer is sent to
hell as punishment by the christian god
jin god azeroth is made blind and
mindless by the elder gods
if we consider derelict's addition to
the mythology then omnipotence is not
the word
which we can use to describe as doth
this however does not make him any less
close to omnipotence it is also reminded
that the powers of such mythological
characters
are subject to change depending on who
writes them as
readers our perception of their strength
and gifts will also change accordingly
when it comes to azeroth there is no
real standard
with which to compare his powers it is
not simply a matter of measuring
physical strength and speed
but one can argue that such a
character's abilities would partly
depend on the reader's imagination as
well
as dot is in some way a puzzle
that the reader must seek to solve on
his or her own
lastly there is the popular view that
aston actually created the universe and
all its contents to his dreams
as long as he sleeps and is kept at
peace by the music of his servants the
music of his servants the world will
continue as it is
his waking up is akin to an apocalypse
where the entire world
and the universe will cease to exist
this is a point that is very similar to
the philosopher
berkeley's idea that perception is
existence
it also reminds us of the simulation
theory where the universe is just
a simulation of some unknown technician
of some higher beings
extra-dimensional beings and it is a
very terrifying thought indeed
so azeroth is one of lovecraft's most
endearing creations
he is haunting while his true form
remains somewhat in the shadows and its
nightmarish
there is also more to be said about this
deity and others in the mythos
they are all connected as darth nair
lethal cthulhu
nigrath and others so now we have come
to the end of this video
do hit that like button for support
subscribe to be a part of this mind cue
family
and hit that bell button for regular
updates on monster videos
right here on minecube